I'm Elaine O'Keefe i'm the executive
director Syrah and i thank you all for
joining us today for this this aids
seminar and i'm very happy to introduce
our guest speaker carol gladly who is
from a sister AIDS prevention research
center she is in at the care program
milwaukee wisconsin milwaukee with jeff
kelly and we've been working
collaboratively with her center and
other aids prevention research centers
on numerous age mutual HIV prevention
research interests she is here today to
talk to you about the issue of HIV
criminalization which is very timely for
multiple reasons including the release
of the new National AIDS strategy and
the emphasis on identifying more people
with HIV with with good goals of getting
them into treatment and preventing and
so on however there could be some
unintended consequences of that
including more emphasis on
criminalization of HIV transmission so
we want to vet that topic today and I
want to point out that dr. bob levine is
here who is the director of our law
policy and ethics core and we're doubly
delighted to have Carol because the law
policy and ethics core is sponsoring a
series of discussions on this very issue
we don't know what the product will be
yet but Carol's input has been vital to
our work and so thank you again my name
is Carol gladly I'm from the center for
AIDS intervention research and I am an
attorney social scientist so I have sort
of dual roles by nature what I do is
very multidisciplinary my law degree and
my PhD work were from The Ohio State
University which has the best football
team on the planet so there you go and i
am here to talk about impact a state
criminal HIV exposure laws on people
living with HIV and actually this is on
people living with HIV in michigan this
was what we think is probably the first
empirical study in the nation perhaps in
the world actually on the impact of
these laws directly on people who have
HIV
so this will give you a little bit of
background for those of you who aren't
familiar with what we mean by HIV
exposure laws 26 US states have adopted
criminal laws that prohibit persons who
have HIV from engaging in sexual
activity with another without prior
disclosure so there's 26 states now this
doesn't mean that in the other states
you can't prosecute someone for not
disclosing and in fact you can the other
states can use regular criminal law for
instance reckless endangerment so just
classic criminal law these states what
they did was went a step further and
created HIV specific statutes so what
they said was we're not going to use the
general criminal law we're going to have
special statutes this was actually
prompted by Ryan White Care Act what
they said was one of the stipulations in
order to be on to get monies from
certain pot of monies from Ryan White
was that every state certified that they
either had a law that they could use an
existing law that they could use to
prosecute people who this is interesting
people who transmitted HIV intentionally
to others or attempted to do so so what
the Ryan White law set is either you
need to certify that you have a law
already that can address intentional
exposure or you need to have an HIV
specific law that will do that so 26
states responded by enacting their own
HIV laws I'll give you some sense of
variability in the laws when you
consider this topic and you're looking
at laws be aware of course as we know
from the constitution powers are left to
the states and less enumerated through
so it ends up that this issue most
criminal law issues are state issues so
there isn't one federal law each state
creates its own statute or uses its long
its own way so we end up having 26
different hiv-specific
laws we also have a variety of other
approaches some states that don't have
an HIV specific law do have what we call
a sentence enhancement and that's what
for instance we have in Wisconsin in
Wisconsin we don't have an HIV
disclosure law or explosion exposure law
but we do have a law that says if you
commit a serious sex crime and you have
HIV your sentence will be enhanced so
you'll have a longer sentence so that's
another way of addressing on HIV
transmission or exposure so the things
you look at when you're considering
these laws is first what's the behavior
that triggers the statute they really go
you can think of them on a continuum
from the most strict to the least strict
the most strict law practically in fact
Michigan is one of them so you'll be
learning about it basically what
triggers them is you even think about
having sex and you've got to disclose
it's not quite that bad but the most
strict law is very easily triggered so
it could be oral sex they could say in
actually in Michigan it's actually
mutual masturbation at that point an
individual needs to disclose they have
HIV and you'll see the statute on the
other end of the spectrum is a statute
like California what triggers that is
unprotected anal or vaginal sex that's
it they don't include oral sex so for
instance in California if you have oral
sex if you have HIV you have oral sex
with someone else you don't have to
disclose at least by that statute and
California's law is even more protective
of people have HIV you'll see with this
next one um culpability when you're
looking at these statues you're going to
look at what's the behavior that
triggers this you're also going to look
at the actor which would be the HIV
positive actor in this situation how
culpable do they need to be and what we
mean by that is is there's a legal term
it's called mens rea at or guilty mind
what intention did they act with so on
the most strict it requires no intention
at all except to have sex with somebody
for instance
and you'll understand this better if you
think of the least strict or the I'm
sorry the least strict is no intention
at all the most strict is you act with
criminal intention you act with malice
you want to infect this infect this
other person so at one end of the
spectrum you have criminal intent at the
other end of the spectrum all you need
to do to trigger this law is have intent
to have sex with somebody so you see how
these work they really do go from very
strict to not so strict on the next one
is requirements they a person who has
HIV needs to do to engage lawfully in
the behavior and these there's not a
whole lot of variation but some laws
require somebody to disclose so to tell
their partner they have HIV some laws
required disclosure and consent now it
doesn't mean that the laws that don't
say consent mean you know you can
legally have non-consensual sex but what
it does mean is in a law that mentions
both disclosure and consent your
prosecutor is going to have to prove
both of those makes it a little more
difficult to prosecute somebody so the
fact is when you're thinking about these
laws are behavior culpability
requirements to engage in the behavior
lawfully and penalty you would be amazed
I'll show you some penalties here but we
the penalties range in the u.s. from 30
days in jail to 30 years in prison it's
just it's really there is so much
variation any questions about that so
far kind of a world wind this is how you
look at HIV statutes okay so now here's
an example of penalties just to kind of
show you they're not exactly playing
around here so look at Arkansas statute
for an HIV specific crime or HIV
specific law and this is heavy duty
Idaho is not more than 15 years or a
fine of no more in excess than five
thousand dollars so these are
significant crimes and to give you a
sense
this I gave you some penalties here
there's comparative penalties in the
model Penal Code which is a model code
for the u.s. rape is minimum of one to
three years maximum of 10 okay so that
gives you an idea and assault with a
deadly weapon minimum of two maximum of
five so we have a lot of statutes a lot
of hiv-specific statutes are certainly
more severe than this okay there are
some significant concerns about these
laws which has led me to studying them
actually it was because these laws in
many ways seems so ludicrous that I
chose this as an area studying and
here's one of the biggest reasons why
these laws are very concerning this is
from Arkansas this is how Arkansas
introduces their hiv-specific law in
their code in their criminal code what
they say is a person with acquired
immune deficiency syndrome is infectious
to others okay through the exchange of
body fluids during sexual intercourse
and needles basically right but look at
this and under these circumstances is a
danger to the public now those of you
with public health backgrounds know how
do you earn the confidence of somebody
who has an infectious disease their
cooperation is essential for us on
stopping the spread of this epidemic
their cooperation is absolutely
essential so how do you get somebody's
cooperation it certainly is not by
telling them they're a danger to the
public health also how do you get people
to get tested right to find out do they
have HIV because we know that people who
are tested and know they have HIV
practice take measures to prevent
transmission right so you want people to
get tested we also have great
medications now we can prolong life this
is a big deal right well one of the ways
you get people to get tested is not
calling them a danger to the public gee
find out if you have this virus
um and then if you do you'll be in
danger to the public so what this setup
and so many of these laws set this up is
this idea of well you made the criminal
law you create criminals and the minute
you create criminals you also create
victims and that's key here because the
public health message about HIV is it's
preventable you can prevent HIV
infection and it's it's in most cases
under your control by practicing safer
sex practicing alternatives to
penetrative sex etc etc right so our
messages this disease is preventable and
you can prevent it well then the law
does exactly the opposite the law says
there are criminals and their victims we
need to step in and protect the public
from these dangers so can you see where
some of the tension starts coming in
okay then here's another one another
concern is the scientific validity of
these laws now this comes from Idaho
okay and we in both of these again are
states that have significant penalties
right in Idaho they say any person who
exposes another in any manner to HIV by
the transfer attempt to transfer of a
body fluid shall be punished right look
what they use as body fluids semen blood
saliva vaginal secretions breast milk
and urine now what do you guys know
about HIV transmission you know I should
have probably figured that out I assume
all of you have some basic HIV is that
true well if you don't it'll begin right
now here's your HIV education urine will
not transmit HIV saliva although we can
detect HIV in saliva it's at such
miniscule levels it's sort of like
dropping a drop of poison in a swimming
pool if we have sensitive enough
equipment we may be able to detect it
but it certainly is not going to get
anybody sick so what they've done in
Idaho is
they have said look this law applies to
transfer blood vaginal secretions we
know breast milk right but look they've
included urine and saliva which won't
transmit HIV so they're actually
prohibiting or requiring disclosure
prior to behaviors that don't transmit
HIV what they're doing by this too is
also miss educating the public right
because we in public health can jump up
and down and say saliva will not
transmit HIV saliva will not you know
you're not going to get HIV because
someone who has HIV sneezes on you but
who's the public going to really think
about or really remember what the public
health people are saying or what the
criminal law is saying which one is more
authority probably it's going to be the
criminal law so here they go and say
things that are new that are contrary to
what we know about HIV okay so those are
some of the concerns now this is the
other thing and then we'll get into my
study but one of the things you need to
think about at least I have been
thinking about a whole lot with this
topic is what's the difference between
the way the people in the law think
about these things and the way we in
public health think about these things
because obviously something's going on
we're not on the same page with this now
what you need to remember there are
mistakes in law clearly urine and saliva
will not transmit HIV but some of the
other things are not so much mistakes as
I believe perspective look in the law
Black's Law Dictionary is sort of the
Webster's for lawyers it's the
definitive source if you've got to
define something you go to Black's Law
look at what blacks law defines as
exposure so it's in a position where the
object that's in the law that's the
person not that we objectify people but
the object spoken of is open to danger
or now watch this where it is near or
accessible to anything which may affect
it detrimentally okay now you think
about this using
this definition the only thing think of
safer sex right sex with a condom so
here is this latex layer in public
health we see that latex layer as
preventing infections we see that as a
life saver right we understand this
latex layer very differently lawmakers
are thinking heck if the only thing
between me and something awful is this
you know micro-fine latex layer this
person is definitely being exposed
exposed to danger so the law many things
that we see is not dangerous the law is
thinking very very differently and
that's one of the big issues about that
near or accessible is that any questions
so the question is how difficult would
it be to remove the words from Idaho's
law and the answer is um you know got 50
years and a whole lot of money it's very
difficult once laws enacted to actually
have it changed especially when it's in
acted poorly in a variety of states the
first date Accord is always going to be
the most difficult then you apply
pressure from the other states but it
would actually be very very difficult
there are absolutely nuts laws though on
the books laws that make no sense on the
books the issue is is that they're not
enforced so one of the ways that you
take away the power of a law is by not
enforcing it so an example is I think
it's Iowa they have a law on the books
that if a person is cross-dressing so if
they're dressing according to a sex that
they are not genetically they have to
have one item of clothing that's
consistent with their genetic sex or
somehow they're violating the law yeah I
mean there's just nuts laws on the books
so one of the ways is you don't enforce
it the challenge is in the United States
we have more prosecutions under these
laws than anywhere else in the world so
um I didn't uh yeah I mean it should be
I should have put it in the citation
let's hope I've done my homework here I
i believe it's 89 it was a 89 oh no this
is the danger to the public shoot okay
well you could be my legal writing
teacher cuz you just point out that i
did not cite it I think it's early it's
got to be yeah yeah um yeah so no
they are indeed enforced and actually
both of them have had prosecutions in
the last two years yeah in the back
comedy cause they're updated the
question is would it be better to repeal
these or amend them modify them and the
answer is I think um people haven't been
asking that question believe it or not
people because there's again this big
schism between public health and the law
scientists who are looking at these and
lawmakers there's a group now that has
come together and they're actually they
have a goal they're going to try to
change this law my bet is they haven't
decided what they're going to do but my
the best strategy I think would be try
to get federal legislation prohibiting
these laws once you do that then you've
got the whole 50 states covered who's
going back lastlaugh the service credit
couple has sex on the brakes
assimilation doesn't work out oh it's
worse than that the condom doesn't have
to break no so on but then somebody's
got to be willing to perjure themselves
probably the way it works is if you
disclose people who have HIV feel very
vulnerable with these laws if you
disclose then have any sort of sex right
let's say you disclose and your partner
agrees to unprotected sex let's say that
they're the insertive partner you know
maybe it's oral sex etc etc so your
partner procedures that they're not too
much at risk so you and you enjoy
whatever you enjoy right then if
something happens later the partner can
say he didn't disclose she didn't
disclose people who have HIV are not
very sympathetic defendants right I mean
who are you going to listen to the
person that says they didn't disclose
and I'm a victim and they're a threat to
me or the person who says I of HIV I
disclosed you need to believe me
so it really it makes people feel very
very vulnerable okay maybe I shouldn't
okay well that's okay we got lots of
time well okay so the question is or the
statement is that if the victim
ultimately dies so HIV is transmitted
and the victim dies it can be prosecuted
as homicide that's what we that was
years ago in states where they used the
the classic criminal law what happened
was they would call it either well they
would call it murder the problem with
prosecuting that is this is again years
ago is that the defendant would often
die before the victim because this was
before we had lots of medications
available so you can certainly try but
you've got to keep your defendant alive
and typically your defendant is going to
have HIV at least one day longer than
your victim so what they did for a while
and still do in some states is attempted
murder that way you don't have to kill
them you just have to show intention to
harm them and that's a different
ballgame actually that's very rare that
we're finding cases where somebody
there's HIV has an intention to hurt
somebody else proving that in court too
is is you know very very difficult so
does that there were times when it was
murder oh but actually I'm sorry
recently there was a saliva case and
attempted homicide what they ended up
saying in that case and I think it was
Iowa no Iowa was a bite there was
somewhere where on what they ended up
saying was this individual had HIV um
kind of one fries short of a happy meal
had some issues going on didn't
understand how HIV was transmitted
believed he could transmit HIV through
saliva was arrested angry spit on an
officer
so they tried to do attempted murder
because it's from his perspective this
is way more legal education that you
ever wanted but attempt is often from
the perspective of the actor not the
victim so if I believe that I can do
something even though it's absolutely
impossible I can still be charged in
most states under um under an intent
okay enough let's but it's a fascinating
I mean this is just an amazing topic of
course it's mine so here's ours yeah
that's okay oh it's a great question so
that the question is did they include
this to see if I interpret the right do
they include saliva and urine because it
accidentally got in there right or were
they really thinking or did they know
they were wrong I guess I don't
understand the question or was there
something big in fact know that you
could not that way but there's but
you're just adding things on so once
it's in the statute and you can give us
acute again that's that's a great
question the answer is I have absolutely
no idea um it the problem is is we can
look back in legislative history
sometimes and you can see what issues
were going around right and so you'll
see maybe a conflict well I think it's
this way I think it's this way um but a
lot of these laws happen before
everything became available on the web
for instance before everything was so
you don't have consistent history with
everything my bet is this is just my
personal belief is back again let's say
89 90 when Ryan White first came out and
said you need to do this on people
especially those who weren't at risk
were nervous about scientific evidence
about transmission so they would say
well yeah you know I know they say you
can't transmit this by urine and
lava but you know those people are in
public health they're liberals don't you
know so we're going to put this in the
law that would be my bet is they were
trying to cover their bases what you'll
see though in law in the state that i
worked in there was it looks like an
actual error so i'll show you that in a
second here on the side they're going to
go on so i cant restate that but it was
a great visit can you hear that okay so
on the the comment is well don't most
laws sort of err on the side of the
victim and so if there is some question
or some issue they'll include urine and
saliva erring on the side of the victim
the answer to that is actually our legal
system is set up to go the other way so
in statistical terms is Type B error but
it's it's on our legal system is set up
so that we are willing to lose more
defendants were actually guilty so we're
willing for them to be found not guilty
then we are to find guilty someone who
is not so actually our whole legal
system is based on the opposite now is
that what happened I don't think so I
really done i think this was this yeah
this is an amazing chunk of history on
where we i mean there's a lot of amazing
chunks of history this happens to be one
where we are actually able to see sort
of fear legislated bias legislated I
mean and it's happened before but it
happened here too I just wanted to say
that
eighties there was widespread opinion
that you can spread HIV by saliva urine
sitting on the toilet seat one of the
most powerful images I saw was a very
famous television actress on network
television was interviewed about this
she said oh you see the actors and the
movies are at much more risk than we are
because they kissed with their mouths
open yeah and rose this image privately
Ewing and Luca question that was one of
the things you know beauty queen types
right and if it's on the television it
has to be true and certainly it's sexier
than public health officials you know
you know they care about dental caries
and you know I don't know washing your
hands and they're not very interesting
and they're hiding things as if that's
in their best interest to do that so
yeah that was there was a lot of
controversy these laws the the earliest
is 88 so that's after there was a
definitive test there was probably some
question and there were lots of
actresses you know our plumbers who
thought for sure this is how HIV could
be transmitted okay on No okay so this
is our study first it starts with
Michigan's HIV disclosure law the reason
that I was so interested when somebody
said couldn't be a mistake in the law is
no that was well is look at this law
okay a person who knows that he or she
is HIV infected that's really important
we fear legislation that doesn't require
this knowledge what we would call
negligent transmission you should have
known you're gay you should have known
for example okay that is happening at
other places in the world not in the US
and not in michigan's law so this is a
person who knows that they're infected
in
ages and sexual penetration with another
person without having first disclosed
okay now watch how they define sexual
penetration sexual penetration means
sexual intercourse which in the law is
typically on penis to vagina cunnilingus
fellatio anal intercourse okay or any
other intrusion however slight of any
part of a person's body or an object
into the genital or anal openings of
another person so what that means is for
example using a sterile let's say nuts
barrel using a non-contaminated sex toy
to pleasure a partner would require
disclosure digital stimulation would
require disclosure we're talking this is
so broad now this one I believe is in
error what it is is is this definition
of sexual penetration comes actually
from some statutes addressing rape now
there are times in rapes where an
individual is either not able to
complete the rape in other words they
can't get an erection or they're being
they don't have a penis for example
because they're a woman or they're
really humiliating the individual so
they're doing things like penetrating
with guns penetrating with things that
are around right so in a rape statute
you do want to include this stuff
because you know you talk about
violating a human that it wasn't you
know a penis still doesn't mean there
was no violation I believe what happened
was came time to write these HIV
statutes and they just took the standard
definition of sex from from the code and
put it into the statute I can't prove
that because again this legislative
history you can't find it but um what
sort of concerning is that there are
four states in the US that adopted this
exact definition
so Michigan where I did my study
Illinois New Jersey and Oklahoma so they
just you know it's like copying the
error so anyway this is a probably the
broadest definition okay so we set out
to answer some research questions
everybody was saying these laws are
terrible these laws are horrible they're
awful they're hurting people etc etc
nobody had ever looked at it empirically
so we thought let's take a look so we
chose a state with a particularly
onerous law and we gathered HIV positive
people and now some questions about
these laws so are questions that guided
the research were are the residents even
aware are HIV positive residence even
where these laws exist is there a
possibility that all of us are sitting
here in academia saying oh they're
terrible they're horrible lots of
activists are but people don't really
know about the laws they did a research
project where they were asking about HIV
testing law and found that nobody was
aware of it they can care about it
anyway so our state residents who are
living with HIV aware this law and do
they understand it um because in order
to have a negative impact or a positive
one you have to have people who are
aware very first question
um this is 2010 20 years 20 something
like 20 long time long long time yeah
okay so are they aware and there were
people would say oh they're not aware
don't even worry about this is not an
issue they don't even know about it just
like they don't know they have to wear
you know one article of clothing okay
then the next question was and this was
a tricky question this is where
researchers get into law is it effective
we had to be willing to find that it was
effective which was not popular and was
kind of risky and I'll give you the
results in just a minute so does the law
increase disclosure you need to remember
though increasing disclosure does not
mean necessarily you're reducing risk
there are certainly evidence out there
that there are people who disclosed and
then choose to have unprotected sex so
we also asked this law decreased
transmission risk not just does it
increase in explos disclosure but then
among those couples does it decrease the
risk then we asked does the law have
these harms these concerns so does it
serve as an inadvertent descent of
disincentive to disclosure what that
means is if you could think about this
kind of ironic but let's say you have
HIV you know that there's a criminal law
out there that regulates your behavior
typically the best way the best side of
a criminal law is nowhere near it right
so if you don't want to take the chance
of being falsely accused etc etc you
don't want people to know you have HIV
so then you're not vulnerable to the law
so that would be a disincentive another
situation we often worry about is let's
say an individual doesn't disclose the
first time right let's say they're in a
state you know that includes oral sex
they don't disclose first time what
happens is this law then provides a
disincentive never to disclose
because then they've broken the law
that's not from a public health
standpoint what you want is that is that
pretty clear okay then does the law
increase stigma remember this is a law
that says people have HIV are basically
criminals or more likely to be criminals
right so we look at hiv-related stigma
are people internalizing these messages
we know hiv-related stigma is associated
with lots of things we don't want like
failure to disclose often failure to
practice safer sex failure take your
medications etc etc so are these laws
inadvertently increasing stigma and are
these laws giving people who have HIV
the message that you are not liked you
are not cared for and are they
generalizing this for instance to the
public health system okay so these are
big big questions and then we asked them
their stance on criminalisation to
participants support or oppose
criminalisation how do people who have
HIV think about these laws and this is
what we found oh no here's our
participants we had 384 participants in
Michigan all of them had HIV they were
it was truly a state sample in that we
divided the state into regions we
recruited in that region in proportion
to the number of people who had HIV that
we're living in that region so it was
truly a statewide sample just over half
of our participants were
african-american just over a third were
female the ages ranged the mean was 43
but clearly I mean you can see with the
standard deviation that um we hit
actually a younger population just over
two-thirds were sexually active this was
interesting because people think all if
you have HIV you're not going to be
sexually active somehow I mean some
people have difficulty conceptualizing
that people who have HIV have active
healthy sex lives so we were able to say
well two-thirds of them were sexually
active in the previous 12 months persons
in the sample representative persons
living with HIV in terms of age race and
actually exposure category but
we did over sample women because I was
concerned we weren't going to get enough
of the women's voices so we actually did
some concerted targeted sampling so our
sample is not representative we had a
few more women okay so here's the
answers to our questions were they aware
of the law seventy-six percent of our
sample were aware of the law so what we
found is there are people who are saying
ad they don't know about these laws you
know this they can't be you know you
can't increase stigma if they don't know
about these laws we were able to prove
that they do indeed at least in Michigan
know about these laws now Michigan has a
policy that people are told about the
laws when they receive their positive
diagnosis they also have a policy that
the Ryan White case managers tell
clients about the law forty-two percent
of our sample of those who are tested in
Michigan said yes I heard about the law
when I was diagnosed which probably
shows you the attention span of somebody
has just been diagnosed right because it
looked like all of them should have been
told about it so Michigan maybe a little
bit different we just finished
collecting data in New Jersey so I'll be
really interested they don't have this
policy I will be interested to see how
many people who have HIV in New Jersey
know about the law but still we're
talking this is part of the cultural
context of HIV in Michigan they know
about this law okay then compliance now
when we did the study we defined
compliance very very strictly so what it
was is a person was in compliance if
they didn't have any unimportant
partners in the previous year we had to
go in the negative okay because of
course once you break a law you've
broken it forever right i mean are you
broken it you're not in compliance
anymore but what that operationalize
that is they need to have personally
disclosed prior to the first time they
engaged in the behavior covered in the
law and actually what we did this is the
one thing that wasn't strict
is we didn't look at mutual masturbation
or some of the other things in the law
that did not pose a risk the reason we
did that was because I didn't want to
reinforce this idea that HIV is
transmitted if you just look at somebody
that was one of the reasons the other
reason is that reliability of data on
mutual masturbation for example is it's
notoriously unreliable so I decided sort
of made you know the executive decision
we weren't going to go there so we just
looked at anal vaginal and oral sex not
only that but the likelihood that you're
going to get a prosecutor who's going to
prosecute somebody for mutual
masturbation without disclosure
hopefully is very slim it hasn't
happened yet so we looked at no
uninformed sex partners and again had to
be before the first time um so check it
out 71 percent of the sample were in
compliance so a lot of people I mean
there were thoughts that um from sort of
the legal side of things oh you know
these people have HIV they're out there
you know and they're infecting everybody
actually that wasn't the case 71 percent
were in clients a hundred percent of
those that weren't having sex or hadn't
had sex in the the last 12 months were
in compliance right because you can't
have any uninformed partners 61 percent
of those who are sexually active were
also in compliance ok that's 61 percent
and that included oral sex whether
giving or receiving okay so we saw high
compliance mm-hmm
we ask that of everyone and um yeah
that's a good question yep we also did
some sub analyses but among people who
knew about the law wait a minute I
misspoke I'm sorry this was actually a
big argument we had was do we include
people who don't know about the law
because of course ignorance of law is no
excuse we settled on these were people
who were aware now I just misspoke again
they can't be the sample size these were
everybody okay yep no actually this is
71 percent of the 384 minus people who
either had inconsistent minus 17 people
inconsistent data or missing data so the
sample 71 percent of the inter pares
right because ignorance of the law is no
excuse that's what yep um so there you
have it you'll see why probably in a
little bit so then the question was is
the law effective this is the big
question right what we did to look at
this is we looked we compared people who
are aware of the law with people who
were unaware of the law the hypothesis
was those who were aware of the law
would be more likely to have no
uninformed partners than those who are
unaware of the law we saw no effect of
the law either with compliance or with
abstinence that could be another effect
of the law right is that people would
just not have sex so neither were um
significant since then or actually about
most three years ago two years ago there
was another study that sort of obliquely
indirectly looked at this issue they
also found no effect of the law so one
of the things we can say right off the
bat is we're not getting a lot out of
this law right there's no effect of this
law
here's the however participants were
where the law disclosed to a greater
proportion before the first time they
had sex it looks like there may be a
timing factor here the law says you need
to disclose before you have sex right in
human relationships what we know with
people of HIV is what we know our most
people will disclose shortly after the
first time often they'll protect their
partner or practice low risk behaviors
right but it's sort of mutual risk you
don't want to disclose until you're at
least involved enough so the other
person's at risk so now you've both you
know sexually interacted there's some
investment on both sides then you
disclose the law doesn't allow these
relationships to develop naturally
instead it says before they even you
know agree you need to disclose so
people who are aware the law did
disclose before so there may be an issue
of timing here mm-hmm we do indeed on
it's not here because of yet limited
time we have partnered by partner
information that well that tells us
obviously was people who we asked on was
this the only time you've had sex with
this person or the only time you were
going to like one-night stand of course
disclosure you would have less often
with those the more partners they had on
the less disclosure that kind of stuff
so nothing really looked particularly
surprising here's another thing that was
sort of interesting among those who are
sexually active and law aware this is
where we start limiting this sample um
sixty-nine percent reported the law was
very important or important in their
decision to disclose we were thinking
people were saying oh you know
disclosure is so you know it is such an
hiv-positive status disclosure to a
prospective sex partner is so complex
think of all the issues that are going
around people saying out of the law
they're not thinking about the law right
so I was
Lee surprised at least as surprised as I
was by how many people knew about the
law was the fact that they found they
said this is very important in my
decision and what's interesting is that
came out self-reported importance and
compliance do have a significant
relationship that suggests that there
may be some effect at least with this
group of the law okay so that's
effectiveness
mm-hmm
and whether in
and I
um well that would that would suggest a
bet the case managers would sort of love
to hear that that would suggest our
clients are actually listening to them
on and I think that sometimes that's not
their experience it could be um and we
actually you know what I can go back and
actually I can run a test to see if
those who are poor you hearing it from
their case manager were more likely yeah
I can actually look at that um if you
want to email me on I can tell you my
gut sense just being in the data for a
long time is that um we're not going to
see the significance with that but boy
wouldn't it be interesting so those are
the post enforcement's I know and don't
know it so let me just move back kinetic
instead of sheriff or check you know
I've come very six months on this sucker
whoa
oh okay that's it that's it's an
interesting question and I just realized
that I'm going to have to kind of whip
through some of this I'm sorry I'd love
this topic and I have managed time the
question though this is an important
issue is that what about enforcement is
somebody checking in on people who have
HIV regularly etc etc depends on what
state they came from i'm running a study
right now that includes tennessee in
tennessee if you are um arrested and
convicted under their HIV law you become
a registered sex offender in that case
you are going to have your behavior
monitored and actually in Tennessee
they've got two kinds of registered sex
offenders those they call violent and
those they call nonviolent guess where
HIV on people who've been brought up on
these like their violent sex offenders
yep so okay then is the law harmful I
looked at comfort with disclosure the
idea being that these laws provide a
disincentive to disclose it was not
significant so people who are where the
law were not less comfortable disclosing
than people who were not aware of the
law I also looked at perceived hostility
did a scale with perceived hostility
that was not significant so people who
are aware the law didn't / seem perceive
the public as more hostile towards
people have HIV um the last one was this
internalized stigma and there was an
association hiv-related stigma was
inversely associated though with
awareness of the law so that's an
inverse association this one was really
puzzling until we thought it through
what this means is that people who were
not aware of the law um scored higher on
this internalized stigma scale than
people who were of course the hypothesis
is if you're aware of a law that
criminalizes people of HIV you're gonna
be um have more stigma when we thought
about this and did some other analyses
though it ends up that people who
weren't aware the law were less likely
to be connected with social networks of
people who have HIV right so because
they're not connected they're not
getting information on the law
because they're not connected they're
likely to experience more stigma they
haven't had the chance to hear other
people's strategies or to be part of the
community for stigma reduction okay
here's the other big surprise this is
among again HIV positive sample ok this
is support for criminalization this
isn't surprising eighty-eight percent on
supported criminalisation of unprotected
sex without disclosure we weren't really
surprised by that but look at this oral
sex with an uninformed partner 64%
supported on criminalization and condom
protected sex half this is not at all
what we thought we were going to see we
saw really significant support for these
laws among our HIV positive sample but
look at these associations these were
the demographic associations with
support of this law women people who
were not white people had less education
and less income these were the folks who
were supporting these laws ok so just so
summary were they aware in Michigan they
sure were the law no there was no
independent effect there were some
trends but no independent effect on the
question is one of the big theory of
compliance in the law is people comply
with things that they agree with right
so if you hold the value you are likely
to agree with the law that holds the
same value so the question is would they
have been inclined to disclose any way
right then harmful we didn't see any
independent effect of the law and then
Stan's surprising support for
criminalization so conclusions I
actually come from the Medical College
of Wisconsin so I sort of the teaching I
do is for medical students etc so this
issue at first do no harm based on what
we found in this study we can't say that
there is any direct harm but what we can
say is that there's certainly the
possible
lydia harm right certainly and always
heir to the conservative at least you
know think of the Hippocratic oath right
first do no harm so don't forward
legislation that may be harmful
especially if you look at it from a
utilitarian perspective especially if
it's not effective so what you're doing
is you're taking a law that isn't
effective and you're risking this harm
right also research consistently just
demonstrates that persons who know
they're infected take steps to protect
others lymari if you've got laws that
may provide a disincentive to testing
for example then first do no harm right
okay then note the characteristics of
persons who support criminalisation back
to the the the issue of women supported
it people who are minority supported it
people would lower income lower
education what I personally think is
happening um is that these are people
who are likely not to have expected they
were at risk or not to feel empowered to
prevent infection so what they're doing
is they're looking to the law to protect
them right when you feel like you're
vulnerable right you feel a
vulnerability you feel like you can't
control it you look to the criminal law
there should be a law against that right
you've heard the phrase right there
should be a law so these are clearly
individuals who are not feeling
empowered to protect themselves whether
it's because they're in relationships
for example where it would be dangerous
for them to try to protect themselves
introduced condoms or because they
didn't even see HIV is on their radar ok
these are people were not meeting their
needs either we're not meeting them
because we didn't sensitize them to
their risk or we're not meeting their
needs because they can't take care of
themselves and in that way it is almost
criminal to have somebody put them at
risk when for instance it would be
dangerous for them to protect themselves
okay then the last conclusion is note
the disconnect between efforts to
address HIV in law and efforts in public
health it's a huge huge disconnect we
haven't looked at this at all nobody's
gone to Black's Law and said how does
how does the law think about exposure
how's that different from what we think
in public health also you'll notice that
a lot of these laws they undermine our
basic public health messages you can
protect yourself HIV isn't transmitted
casually so there you have it that's a
study